good big van Beethoven's seventh
Symphony performed by the Vienna
Symphony Orchestra each summer bong
honors its most famous son by holding a
month-long festival in the composer's
honor the Beethoven fest is a festival
for the entire city Sunday's concert was
broadcast live on bonds market square as
the solution it's tough for newcomers to
gain an appreciation of classical music
so an event like this is just a thing
you can just come and enjoy the
atmosphere we have a good easy necessary
it's really nice actually it's so cool
to be in the city web Halloween was born
and through here this music so this is
really fantastic idea so I recommend
everyone to come to bond to this
festival the great-granddaughter of
recant vogner nikka Vagner has headed
the festival since 2014 she's using
public screenings to bring the people of
Bon closer to their composure Beethoven
I find it's just a nice gesture towards
the city the Beethoven hull is quite
large but it can't accommodate
everyone's and its pleasant to be
outdoors to come and go wrap yourself in
a blanket and bring a beer along
1200 people gather to watch and listen
the beat Horton fest has been holding
public screenings since 2007 Deutsche
Welle organizes them we're based here in
bonds we feel very comfortable here and
are glad to give something back to the
city it's also extremely important to us
because we're cultural mediators and
conveying culture means making it
possible to experience culture together
with others we want to enable people to
enjoy classical music here together with
others to have a shared experience thank
you my deepest of the main program
consists of 54 events performed 22
different venues the baton fest has
changed under Nika varnas leadership for
the first time the lineup includes a
dance performance at bongs opera house
changes is the motto of this year's
festival yeah of linda's Beethoven Fez
we're opening up the Beethoven faster
more than just music spa to appeal to a
younger audience we're teaming up with
the theater if open on smitten Tata on
the other hand Beethoven is our local
hero and he is of course the focus on so
there's a lot of Beethoven skipped feel
Beethoven but the Beethoven fest isn't
just a venue for the big stars budding
young musicians also get the chance to
show off their talents
like French cellist aurélien paske
we are in this kind of small room and
this really intimate so I'm yeah I'm
nervous because of the quality of the
angel reputation official but the place
looks Li consorting in I hope there will
be no such thing as nervous breakdown
bomb is in bait home fever the
celebrations will continue in concert
halls and public spaces until October
the fourth